MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, Tianzi.
TIANZI CAI: Hi, Martin.
What's going on?
MARTIN OMANDER: I'm
writing a ride hailing
app that matches cars
with riders in real time
using Pub/Sub.
I noticed some glitches.
And I wondered if
you could help me.
TIANZI CAI: A ride hailing
app, that sounds super cool.
Pub/Sub has released several
new features this year.
I wonder if some
of them could help.
Could you tell me more
about your use cases?
MARTIN OMANDER: Of course.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER: When a
rider requests a ride,
the rider's mobile app sends
an HTTP post to a Cloud Run
service called Rider Handler.
That service publishes
a message to Pub/Sub.
The message is consumed
by the Dispatcher service.
The Dispatcher service calls
the Fleet Manager service
to find nearby drivers.
It then sends a
push notification
to the nearest driver via
Firebase Cloud Messaging.
When a driver accepts
or declines a ride,
their mobile app
calls a cloud run
service called Driver Handler.
That service publishes
a message to Pub/Sub,
which is consumed by the
Fleet Manager service.
Pub/Sub lets me
decouple Rider Handler
from Dispatcher and Driver
Handler from Fleet Manager.
It also lets me add more message
subscribers in the future,
for example, for reporting.
TIANZI CAI: Thank you for
showing me how the app works.
I see how Pub/Sub fits in now.
Let's see the issues you face.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, the
first issue I'm facing
is caused by malformed GPS
data from riders' phones.
It's still a little bit of a
mystery to me how this happens,
but when a dispatcher receives
Pub/Sub messages with bad GPS
data, it throws an
exception and doesn't
acknowledge the message.
When there are many
such bad messages,
new ride requests don't
make it to the dispatcher.
TIANZI CAI: Oh, no.
It sounds like
you've got a growing
backlog of undeliverable
messages in your Pub/Sub topic.
Could you show me the
graphs for unacked message
count and oldest
unacked message?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
I went into the Pub/Sub
area of Cloud Console
and I took these screenshots.
TIANZI CAI: Ah.
This confirms my suspicion.
Let me explain.
A small backlog is harmless.
But a huge backlog could
cause all your messages
to be stuck because
Pub/Sub always
tries to deliver the
oldest messages first.
You never want a
situation where the number
of undelivered messages grows
with the age of the oldest
message.
It looks like you have
that kind of backup.
And it's causing
new messages to be
stuck behind the old messages.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh.
I see.
What should I do?
TIANZI CAI: You should
use a [INAUDIBLE] cue.
You could tell
Pub/Sub to forward
the undeliverable messages
to a different topic,
also known as a
dead letter topic,
after a certain number of
failed delivery attempts.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, really?
Can I update an
existing subscription
to send bad messages
to a dead letter queue?
TIANZI CAI: Absolutely.
Let's go to Cloud
Console to do that.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
TIANZI CAI: Let's go to your
subscription dispatcher-sub.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
TIANZI CAI: Edit it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Edit.
Yep.
TIANZI CAI: We want to
scroll down to Dead Lettering
and enable Dead Lettering.
MARTIN OMANDER:
This checkbox here?
TIANZI CAI: That's right.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Dead Letter Topic.
TIANZI CAI: You want to create--
MARTIN OMANDER: You said--
TIANZI CAI: Yes.
Create a Dead Letter topic
to forward the messages.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
So I'll call that
riders-dead-letter-topic.
TIANZI CAI: You also want to
attach a default subscription
to your dead letter topic.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
I'll call that
riders-dead-letter-subscription.
TIANZI CAI: Sounds great.
How many times do you want
Pub/Sub to try before it
forwards the bad messages?
MARTIN OMANDER: So
this is how many times
it will have to fail
in dispatcher before it
comes into this
subscription, is that right?
TIANZI CAI: That's correct.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
Maybe 10 times.
If it doesn't work after
10, it will never work.
TIANZI CAI: Now you
can click Update.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
TIANZI CAI: And you want
to go to Dead Lettering.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, yeah.
There's an orange
triangle there.
Oh.
TIANZI CAI: This is to
grant Pub/Sub the publisher
and subscriber role so
that it could forward
the messages on your behalf.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, I see.
So I just granted these roles.
TIANZI CAI: Yes.
You will expect
messages that exceeds
the maximum number
of delivery attempts
to be forwarded to
your Dead Letter topic.
MARTIN OMANDER: Excellent.
I should ask for someone who
knows more about GPS data
to write a service that
subscribes to that Dead Letter
subscription and do
a full diagnosis.
TIANZI CAI: They will have
all the bad data in one place.
I think they will
appreciate that.
MARTIN OMANDER: The second
issue I have is mistakenly
sending cars to pick up
a rider who has canceled.
First, the rider sends
a request ride message.
Next, the rider sends
a canceled ride message
if they want to cancel the ride.
And for some reason, the
canceled ride message sometimes
arrives first.
When it does, the dispatcher
doesn't know about this ride
yet, so it can't cancel it.
And then later the request
ride message comes in.
And the dispatcher
then creates the rides
and finds a driver for
this canceled ride.
TIANZI CAI: This sounds like
messages were definitely
arriving out of order.
But Pub/Sub Message
Ordering could help.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, excellent.
Please tell me more.
TIANZI CAI: I imagine
requests matter per rider.
When these requests are
published to Pub/Sub,
if you attach the rider's
ID as an ordering key,
then these messages will be
delivered in the same order
they are received by Pub/Sub.
The request ride message will
arrive in a dispatcher service
first, followed by the
cancel ride message.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, and
this would make sure
that the dispatcher
is always using
the latest, correct information
about each ride, right?
TIANZI CAI: Exactly.
MARTIN OMANDER: I
want to give it a try.
How do I set it up, Tianzi?
TIANZI CAI: To set it up, let's
go to Cloud Console again.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
I'm here.
I go into Subscriptions.
TIANZI CAI: Let's
recreate a dispatcher sub
so that it has ordering enabled.
MARTIN OMANDER: So I
start by deleting it.
Is that right?
TIANZI CAI: That's right.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Delete.
Then I'll create a new
or replacement for it.
So I'll call it
dispatcher-sub-ordered
because--
TIANZI CAI: It sounds great.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
And it's the rider's topic.
It's push because we're using
Cloud Run on the other side.
And this is my
Cloud Run end point.
And I'm just recreating
what I'd done
on the previous subscription.
So I enabled
authentication for it.
I set up an account for that.
And then there was something
I should do differently.
Ordering?
TIANZI CAI: Yes.
MARTIN OMANDER: Is this it?
You want to enable
message ordering.
MARTIN OMANDER: Very good.
And that's it?
TIANZI CAI: That's it.
You can click Create.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
TIANZI CAI: And in
the meantime, I'm
going to publish a
request ride message
from Bobcat followed by a
cancel ride message from Bobcat.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
I'm selecting the log for
dispatcher service here.
And there I see a
request ride from Bobcat.
And let's see what is this.
TIANZI CAI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
And the cancel ride from Bobcat.
Our drivers will
appreciate this.
They came in in the right order.
TIANZI CAI: That's
great to hear.
MARTIN OMANDER: Cool.
So with Dead Letter queues
and message ordering enabled,
I'm eager to test
out a new version
of the algorithm in
the dispatcher that
matches riders and drivers.
TIANZI CAI: Definitely.
It will be cool to compare
the algorithms side by side.
I'm thinking, if you
can replay the messages,
you can compare
the new algorithm
with the old algorithm.
MARTIN OMANDER: Cool.
That sounds fantastic.
But, Tia, can you explain
what replay means?
TIANZI CAI: To
replay messages, you
need to create a Snapshot
on a given subscription.
Another way to think
about a snapshot
is to consider it a
recording that you start.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
I have a subscription which
hits the production dispatcher.
We just saw it.
If I want to replay messages
to my test dispatcher
and compare it with the one
in production, can I do that?
TIANZI CAI: Absolutely.
Let's head over to Cloud
Console to do that.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Let me just first
grab the address
for the test dispatcher.
All right.
So I grabbed the URL
for the test dispatcher.
And I'm going to Pub/Sub
subscriptions now.
TIANZI CAI: Yes.
Let's go to
dispatcher-sub-ordered.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Dispatcher-sub-ordered.
I'm going into that one.
TIANZI CAI: Let's go
into the subscription
and to create a snapshot.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
TIANZI CAI: Yep.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great snapshot.
All right.
TIANZI CAI: Let's
give it a name.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Maybe I'll call it begin-test.
All right.
TIANZI CAI: And now we
want to go ahead and create
a new subscription
using this Snapshot.
So go to Subscriptions.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
Create new
subscription you said?
TIANZI CAI: Yes.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
I think I might call this
test-dispatcher-subscription.
And this will be the same
topic as the previous one.
Still push because I'm pushing
to a Cloud Run service.
Here's the URL for my
test to dispatcher.
I've set up a service account.
They can publish.
It's allowed to publish.
And allowed to call
the Cloud Run service.
And, sorry, what more
should I do here?
TIANZI CAI: You want it to
retain acknowledged messages.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, there it is.
Retain acknowledged messages.
Yeah.
TIANZI CAI: And go ahead
and create the subscription.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
TIANZI CAI: Very
quickly, Martin, could we
go back to
dispatcher-sub-ordered
and also retain
acknowledged messages
in dispatcher-sub-ordered
as well.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh.
Yes, of course.
Good, good thinking.
Sorry, was it retain
acknowledged messages?
TIANZI CAI: That's right.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
TIANZI CAI: I'm going
to go ahead and publish
some messages.
In the meanwhile, you can
go to your test subscription
and seek to the snapshot
that you just created.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh.
OK.
Test dispatcher sub.
And replay messages.
And Seek to a
snapshot, you said.
TIANZI CAI: Yes.
MARTIN OMANDER: Picking a test.
OK.
Should I hit seek?
TIANZI CAI: Yes.
MARTIN OMANDER: Very good.
Replaying messages.
TIANZI CAI: And now we
can look at your logs
to see some messages
that are just published.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
I'm in the logs.
I'm going to filter so that I
only see the test dispatcher.
Only see the messages
from the test dispatcher.
Let's see here.
So test dispatcher received
a request ride from Starfish.
And let's see if
there were any more.
I'll run this again.
Test dispatcher received a
Pub/Sub message request ride
from Penguin.
A request ride from Gopher.
And finally, there was a
request ride from Starfish.
Cool.
TIANZI CAI: That's awesome.
MARTIN OMANDER: So
any point, I can
go back and replay these
and send them over and over
to the test dispatcher?
TIANZI CAI: The snapshot
will be there for seven days.
So you can go back and replay
as many times as you want.
MARTIN OMANDER: Cool.
So I see that I can
seek to a snapshot.
And the other option I see here
is to seek to a point in time.
This is a really
powerful feeling,
being able to jump
around in time.
TIANZI CAI: Right?
It's empowering.
But we should probably also
want to do with caution
by reading the docs carefully.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah,
I can't agree more.
We time travelers know
that we must always read
the documentation carefully.
I feel like I've learned a lot
today, Tianzi, dead lettering,
ordering, snapshot, and seek.
Thank you for showing me
these Pub/Sub features.
TIANZI CAI: My pleasure, Martin.
Let me know how your
ride hailing app does.
[MUSIC PLAYING]